melania trump is telling her friends
that she has no interest in being first
lady again despite her husband's 2024
teases report this is an insider story
uh several of melania trump's friends
told cnn she had no interest in
returning to the white house let alone
helping if her husband decided to run
former president trump hasn't declared a
2024 candidacy but has teased the
possibility saying her his supporters
will be very happy with his decision
previous reports said melania trump was
happy and relaxed since exiting the
white house earlier this year she
largely remained out of the public eye
unlike some of her peredes
predecessors and has
made a few public appearances so do you
think she really wants to be a first
lady again zero percent no i i agree so
if i have to believe one of these two
stories i think this is the one i
believe in because i don't think she
ever wanted that kind of no eyeballs i
think she just wanted to be at peace
yeah the toxic i mean it was so tough
how is that going to play a role if he
because i 100 think trump's running
again you're saying you're at 90 percent
you're at where i'm gonna ask him when i
interview him in three weeks i like i'm
sure he'll double the question like he's
been ducking the questions i'm gonna i'm
gonna put it i'm gonna
i need to guess
uh as close to 100 as possible okay so
you're 90 100 100 and then only that
only 10 is looking at if we can if we
can get the election integrity laws
passed and stop the massive voter id
uh debacle that is what stole the last
election
we can't have mass mail in voting like
that we've got to have voter id laws
there's got to be something in place to
make sure that we as americans all of us
no matter what side of the aisle we're
on can have trust and faith in the
election process i think we can all hope
whether you're on left or the right that
covet is not here in 2020 freaking for
wait what are you talking about what are
you talking about i hope that it's not a
major factor like in this process
stop it
you
okay are you serious listen in a game of
war when you see a play that works you
have to figure out a way
to use it again and again this is this
was a proven
they're going to remix it
they're doing it how many different
variants are there right now they're
doing it now mailing ballots work
for fraud does mail-in ballots work
to get as creative as you want as
possible i don't care whether you
believe whatever happened here listen
biden's the president today but does
mail-in ballots work to be able to
manipulate more than you coming and
showing your idea obviously okay so so
to me i'm not even saying that happened
or didn't happen all i'm saying to you
is you can get more creative with mail
and balance than you can
with ids you think they're gonna let
that go
no way listen when you play football
you're gonna you're gonna continue the
same play if they cannot stop your
running back what do you do keep running
through the middle they can't stop keep
running until you found a play to stop
it i'm running through your linebackers
because your guys suck today they're
gonna figure right away covet may not be
around 2023 something's going to be
around 20 20 23 to create a shutdown but
that's why what david is saying that as
far as the honest is so important let me
give you a flip perspective she'll give
you a flip person before okay if you're
saying that's the playbook shut it down
i think that would actually be a bad
look on biden his whole candidacy is
like i'm going to take care of coach no
you don't i'm going to take care of you
and if it's still around 2024. do you
remember an issue for him to a community
i'm at a restaurant
uh the lady outside she's sitting there
she's saying let me tell you something i
cannot believe in the state of florida i
don't see anybody wearing a masculine
valley with a mask on what an
irresponsible no wonder all of these
people in the state of florida are so
sick look at these no one has a mask on
she's hollering at me and i don't have a
mask and i'm outside waiting for my car
so man where are you outside i see ma'am
where are you from yeah i said man where
are you from i'm from the responsible
state
of california i said oh really yeah says
well you know there's a reason why so
many people are leaving your state
because they're being forced to do
things they don't want to do which means
what there is a group of people that
think shutting down is the responsible
thing to do and you're forgetting that
audience there's a group of people that
say dude what a what a responsible guy
here knew some you know oh my gosh reed
hastings is he a pretty smart guy he's a
hunter on netflix he runs a 200 billion
dollar company is he pretty a smart guy
he gave three million dollars to newsome
to keep him in there why is he do you
think he reid has a dummy no there's a
group of people that think what he's
doing is right well dude think about it
if you're the ceo of netflix you don't
want people going to the damn movie
theater you want people at home watching
that even even if that's the argument
even if that is the argument
even if that's the argument even if
that's the argument still he's not a
dummy there are a lot of smart people
that have done well for themselves that
are going to support a nuisance that are
going to support somebody that stays
home rather than going to work yeah
there's a lot of people that are
lobbying for that so a lot of us are
people that uh support communism and
hate capitalism too i don't we're not
here to disagree on that point all i'm
saying to you is when it comes down to
2023 2024 there's a group of people that
think it's responsible to shut down so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]